ich muss kurz mal googeln ich muss mal
googeln moment müssen kurz mal gucken
was ein loch ist ein loch ist ein see
offensichtlich und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video in dem wir heute
einfach mal testen ob ich dumm bin
es gibt eine website teste dich.de wird
mir luca empfohlen nach unbedingt einen
testlauf textet erste dich steht dir und
wir machen jetzt heute den bin ich dumm
test auf test.de wir haben hier herunter
15 fragen glaub ich 15 fragen geben wir
noch nicht durch geschaut und wir
schauen uns auch mal rein warum machst
du den test ich weiß nur dass ich dumm
bin weil ich beweisen dass ich gut bin
fertig ist
ich bin eigentlich mit diesem test
wirklich ich möchte einfach gewissheit
haben
wir müssen einfach gewissheit bekommen
wir müssen einfach gewisser bekommt am
ende dieses videos heute werdet ihr
wissen wie du mich bin dein partner will
mit ihr schluss machen wie reagierst du
ich bin den restlichen prämiert wie
würde ich eher gehen würde auf jeden
fall als erstes erstmal trauma
spielen und dann deprimiert gar nicht
schade ich bin ein einzelgänger was hat
das mit dummheit zu tun
dieses gefühl diese webseite wir jetzt
einfach nur dinge über mein privatleben
erfahren was kommt als nächstes so wie
groß ist ein geschlechtsorgan
motherfucker fackel heute bei der
dummheit ist nicht mal beziehungs
verhalten aber okay wir wollen wir
wollen ernsthafte antworten
ich tendiere zu ich bin ein anzug einzel
einzel clique die aber deiner wahl an
ja ich weiß ich weiß oder sehen wir
immer mit solchen fragen alter die
wollten einfach die domain anhängen auf
jeden fall hier ja eine ziege steht auf
der grenze zwischen deutschland und
spanien
wer darf sie merken was ist was ist
deutschland deuten und spanien sind
keine nachbarländer
das ist spanien auf mich so schwieriges
zu fragen sind alles sehr sehr negative
antworten auf schwierige fragen dass es
zu verdreht die frage was ist die
hauptstadt von deutschland
hamburg hamburg berlin hamburg hamburg
leute leute leute es juckt mich in den
fingern juckt mich in den fingern
einfach hamburg anzuklicken weiland
ohren hat ja auch schon gesagt trainer
hat ein kreuz von hier bis nach hamburg
denn nicht gesagt hat ein kreuz von hier
bis nach berlin
deswegen liegt der verdacht nahe dass
hamburg die hauptstadt von deutschland
ist bisher was wir müssen wir müssen
gucken wir müssen kurz verspielten
hauptstadt deutschland damals berlin die
hauptstadt in deutschland viele leute
die haben uns jetzt geheim die
informationen besorgt sagt niemandem
weiter und verbreitet zwar nicht im
internet berlin
ppr sagt berlin okay gut ich bin
zuversichtlich bin zuversichtlich ich
glaube am ende des tages sie mir
vielleicht doch nicht dumm erhoffst du
dir ein gutes ergebnis ja auch keins
dieser ach das ist ein lgt seite gibt es
man wird denkt sich so eine scheiße aus
gibt es in london den dreißigsten 2
nein die schule monate haben 28
diese frage ist an sich eine person
krasser brain fakt dass man sich erst
einmal vor augen halten vor augen halten
warte ich halt mir war dann okay
28 tage leute ich hab noch meine
reaktion ist die beste hand wurde darauf
wie viel er das einem zehn mal zehn
meter großen loch zehn mal zehn meter
wenn man jetzt mal so drüber nachdenkt
leute warteten
ich muss kurz vor winterbeginn moment
müssen kurz mal gucken was ein loch ist
ein loch ist ein sehr offensichtlich mit
einem monster hier drin
stiftsschule mittel eventuell will
schlittschuh mit löchern kaufmann was
ist mit dieser welt los du kannst doch
kalte füße wenn der löcher drin sein
alles klar werden das sind einfache
leute diese bewusst schlittschuhlaufen
gehen und sich daher mit dem fuß zu
portieren können sie mir glauben leute
ihr könnt mir das wirklich glauben okay
jetzt herausgefunden ein loch ist ein
see see ist als ansammlung von wasser
definiert um hier als ansammlung von
erde
ausgetrickst was für einen beruf hatte
der zug auf der der zuckerwatte erfinder
nerv jemand anderen mit einem fragen
selbstverständlich werde ich auch mal so
einen deutschen schäferhund vor der
irgendeinen blinden über die straße
hilft der diesen winden begleitet seit
zehn jahren läuft über die straße und
denkt sich so wurff wurf war dann klaute
erstmal seinem ehrlicher das telefon bin
und ich kann eigentlich reden aber ich
tue so als könne nun reden wir müssen
zuckerwatte finden die homebox maxi
müssen wir müssen zuckerwatte wenn ich
unbewusst passiert 100% historically
accurate der blindenhund auf jeden fall
gleich geschafft in welcher altersgruppe
bist du sag ich nicht nur bis 15.15 bis
30 ich sage ich man dieses verlag schon
viel zu viele informationen da die
geschlechtsorgane frage kommt
wahrscheinlich auch noch wie fandest du
diesen tanzt alles klar hier wird die
konfiguration von finden
du fandest dass es ist tatsächlich
richtig alter es ist auch richtig dass
es ein geklammert ich kann nicht mehr
deutschmann wie solchen test überhaupt
bestehen wann ist es so klar ich werde
volle punktzahl 100 von 100 bananen auf
der dummheit skala bekommen joja moment
mal seht ihr das da unten abhotten steht
seit wann ist abhotten ein deutsches
wort frage um frage ist diese frage
schwer
was ist frage ja nicht wirklich
hoffentlich ist es bald vorbei alter
haben jetzt wirklich meine grenzen
gebracht ich meinen kopf raucht
ich bin vollkommen bin kurz davor der
dänische krone zu essen ihr wisst ich
habe ihn immer gut ausgestattet mit
dänischen kronen hier zum beispiel ein
wunderschönes fünf krone stück sehr gut
gegen kopfschmerzen aber die sache ist
sie dann aber ein bisschen schmutzig
werden schon was ich für denen in der
hand aber okay jetzt leute die
auswertung jetzt wird's spannend
die auswertung und co du bist so klug
wie eine möhre
sie haben sechs von 15 aufgaben richtig
beantwortet alles klar also ich bin auf
jeden fall unterdurchschnittlich schlau
oder überdurchschnittlich dumm und fast
100 52.000 menschen haben dieses quiz
auch schon gemacht vor dem gewissen klug
komma wie eine möhre
ich glaube nicht dass dein kummer
hingehört ehrlich gesagt dieses quiz hat
mir auf jeden fall körperlich verletzt
das ist körperverletzung den melden
jetzt illegale inhalte
ich will dieses chris an die
administratoren melden weil es gegen die
bestimmung von testern verstößt ihr name
am lg slate illegale inhalte
körperverletzung alles leider etwas
gutes getan
wir haben die welt ein stückchen besser
gemacht und damit kümmern uns vor diesem
video verabschieden wir sehen uns morgen
wieder mit dem nächsten einer neuen
folge hacker schau mit dem special guest
also bis dahin haut rein macht's gut und
wisst ihr was macht ein gewinnspiel wir
machen gewinnspiel unter allen leuten
die dieses video licon wird dieser
bleistift verlust ist ein besonderer
bleistift denn seht ihr das hier
dem fehlt teilweise punkte die ich
eigenhändig abgekoppelt habe also wer
diesen wunderschönen bleistift haben
wollte einfach ein leichter lassen und
ihrem jeder der das nike da das kriegt
diesen beispiel für post zugesendet alle
den gleichen auch